salut on est sûrs alliés d'isolation
pour la suite voilà knew too much et
squeeze bla bla bla bla aujourd'hui on
en était là voilà on était tombé d'un
conduit je crois oui de celui ci ont été
atterrés ici les sauvegardes et on est
là voilà bla bla bla bla c'est parti à
trois mecs armés et ça sonne me fait un
petit peu peur je pense que vous passez
par là déjà ça m'a l'air d'être la seule
issue il faut trouver un cylindre de
pression juste pas trop quoi pour
réparer l'ascenseur voilà et ben on va
passer par là où y'a un mec qui est
décédé très bien à la regarder en [ __ ]
c'est passé on va du conduit en compte
et quoi c'est incroyable hop là on a
trouvé la sortie
j'espère juste qu'on va pas nous prendre
en flagrant délit au woods a réussi
et pourquoi la lune et s'intéresse
uniquement à - puis s'intéresse pas aux
trois mecs en bas avec de la barbe et
les pages en compte de la barbe c'est ça
et qu'est ce qui nous dit que cela
mandat qu'on est en train de jouer elle
a pas de la barbe est aussi bordel et
servant d'appât et ben elle va s'en
faire greffer voilà ont sauvé la partie
à cette porte là qu'on doit accéder
juste là sauf que je suppose qu'on va
passer devant ces [ __ ] haut
je crois que la n va les buts et ya la
lienne labaki les buts moi je trace mon
balai steak au plat salut je m'en fous
de cet alliage eux l'ignorent et la 2d
sauvegarde en l'espace de deux minutes
seulement sauvegarde et tu vivras
heureux mon ami niveau de sécurité trop
élevé mais commence à la bahia d'android
regarder mais qui sont pas réveillés au
jour décembre bien là où il ya la lienne
voire même que cette échelle sort de sa
bouche en fait comme ça quand j'arrive
en bas je suis directement dans lui il
ya plus d appuis aucun problème trouver
un moyen d'ouvrir la porte
utilisez-les android a envoyé voilà
brave finalement j'avais raison c'est la
lienne ils développent des 6e 7e 8e sens
chez moi oh [ __ ] je ne sens pas
rétablir le courant comme un moyen
d'allumer l'android de réquisition
encore une sauvegarde
alors maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on a
utilisées au liège peut accéder au
niveau 2 au niveau de la sécurité tout
ça c'est génial du cours à un retourné
en haut pour pouvoir pirater leur dis je
suppose hop là nous revoilà la hausse
est fantastique
alors c'est parti prône administrateurs
obtenu du coup je peux au
activement le droit de réquisition dans
sa cabine à l'adq ou faut que j'aille
là-bas oh ça fait un max de bruit vous
avoue que j'ai vraiment pas envie de
retourner là-bas en bas je sais pas s'il
y avait des airs de tyroliennes la y
aurait aucun problème mais ce n'est pas
le cas donc j'espère juste qu'il va être
gentil up à les stopper sans bruit bah
oui où qu'ils soient gentils faut
surtout pas de chanteur un vol vers ou
plaident pour lui bonjour android
bonjour j'ai besoin de compression oui
rayon bébé
suivent et me fais pas trop de bruit
s'il te plaît si tu fais du bruit beau
déjà aussi à la manière de le suivre que
je suis pas du tout en confiance quoi je
pense qu'il va briguer un moment donné
il va se mettre à déconner nous y voilà
votre de confiance trouve à l'extrémité
de cette frange et à il ya de la bonne
grosse électricité aller le conduit au
non parce qu'en fait tu rentres
l'adorent mais ça mène à rien et il est
passé où landry hétu sortie du truc
était plus là ah oui il est mort [ __ ]
il a voulu passer le conte à ben voilà
par la up
c'est la sérénité si regardez regardez
il est là hop je les trouvais remplacer
le composant de l'ascenseur en double
sens que je vais dire là a coûté on se
connaît bien maintenant et les vrais
amis la sauvegarde de chamelle oubliés
ils me disent de remplacer le composant
ah oui voilà ça m'a fait peur je pensais
qu'il allait retourner à l'aube ou de
l'ama pour établir leur au moins de
bruit en ont on s'en va plus vite que ça
s'il vous plaît allez allez allez allez
ça va c'était pas si durant cette phase
trouver la sortie vers la centrale de
fuite synthétique et là on est bien dans
ce genre d'endroit que la lienne m
l'endroit fin un petit peu très peu
lumineux avec un une petite odeur de
fraise un peu dans l'ère aulas a
j'ai trouvé c'est là que je dois aller
ou pas attendez on va voir ah ben voilà
elle à la guerre de 3i de cimade
que se passe-t-il ça sent les l'aliène
là un jeu soit il avait du talent ça
sent le talk l'appui aux cinématiques
je vous avais fait les efforts les
maternelles à dire sur la station comme
je voulais dit on n'a pas entendu votre
message
on pense
c'est moi c'est calme identifiez vous
ripley je viens du torrent oui je vais
chercher un cadeau
alors elle va comment la déprécie face
ici marshall
ce sont les forces de sécurité juste
sous vos yeux abba bon travail un [ __ ]
bravo à vraiment j'ai vu la créature
qu'est ce que c'est ça c'est pas quelque
chose à mener ici par marleau le
capitaine de la nati doha le vaisseau
qui a trouvé la boîte noire a est bien
trouvée c'est en 2003 où l'on soit en
sécurité ici
la créature se balader les synthétiques
de six hommes sont pas très coopératif
ou pas très drôle de merde voilà qu'elle
aura besoin de soins taylor a besoin de
soin de soi oui oui oui il ya une unité
d'assistance respiratoire au qg
alors allongé fort utile de travail pour
se rendre au qg mais il est en panne
la salle de contrôle des trois et se
trouve à l'étagé ça me dit que vous êtes
ingénieur à les dom ordre utile comme
c'est vous qui avez fait fourrer le
piège répète ça répète ça se bat jusqu'à
marquer marchal sur ta casquette le dr
respect les cards au virus à fréquence
radio pourquoi sans contact et toi tu
t'appelles ricardo ainsi raison de plus
pour que tu baisse les yeux
vous allez bien les clés ça marche et
ben franchement je suis très fier des
développeurs parce que nous faire
marcher des kilomètres dans les buts un
escalier il faut les former des
ascenseurs etc c'est fantastique merci
développeurs d'aliéner flassian à
réactiver le transit sur la console
principal schéma grenades aveuglantes v2
hockey nokia ça ne dit rien de bon mais
rien de bon mais qu'est ce qui se passe
qui fait du bruit comme ça [ __ ] y'a un
mec qui tape contre cette porte tu la
fermes [ __ ] alors faut que j'aille sur
la console pour rétablir le transit non
intestinale et boum utiliser erreur
puissance faible désactiver les verrous
de sécurité
oh non je me cache ses cachets et on
veut du mal ou pas est ce qu'il a un gun
faut repérer il a en gold et nous veut
du mal bobitch c'est génial parce que du
coup appuyé le buter sur un tir et la
vienne par contre ce qui est moins
jeunesse et du coup on a pu le teaser on
regarde ya de la fumée qui sort de lui
il est bien grillé à hong kong et
maintenant vas tu embrocher sur un pic
et puis tu va servir de viande à grec
pour tous les jeunes de 15-18 ans qui
achètent des grecs à l'ascension est
cassée désormais ça c'est fantastique
c'est une super nouvelle vraiment
chalumeau requis mais oui
le film ou utiliser le levier 1up peu
utilisé alors qu'est ce qu'elle fait
avec mais traîne sur un conseil
principal du coup désormais je peux
comme ils sont bas les steaks mais non
leurs saloperies
il avait réussi à s'enfuir le vilain ils
fument aussi allé de viande à grec
nickel on sait maintenant comment tous
les grecs paris s'approvisionnent en
viande alors du coup je pourrais
utiliser ça suit activation du transit
intestinal intestinale retourner à la
gare de transit
ripley 6 voiles ce transit et là on vous
attend mais bien évidemment ça va être
la mère pour partir et ben voilà voilà
l'ascenseur est cassée au [ __ ] vous
qu'ils vont prendre une voiture et moi
je prendrais la voiture d'après as là je
sens que ça va être la merde y'a t'il un
outil pour moi ici chalut et bientôt il
faudra un plus gros ça qu elle commence
à voir beaucoup de choses sont inventés
entre les grenats le gall le chalumeau
la barre et hop on rejoint et pour la
nique à ça fait penser au rouge à lèvres
des totally spies
balazs idée est de retour à la gare de
transit en vrai mais ils sont plus là il
va y avoir la lienne j'ai entendu des
voix en partant fais gaffe qui est là je
vais l'appeler et c'est là il va y avoir
des bons gros mais qui vont arriver
elle a entendu des voix mais y'a
personne se défend tant que tu as
entendu mon gars au nom bien mais qu
allait bien plus tard d'ascenseur chypre
échéant position allait j'ai fait une
bombe aveuglante un quart des eaux
d'oran et des noix de cajou suprême à la
fois café ou oui toi c'était un mauvais
flore mais ça c'est le duo de rendre
votre camouflage mais dépistage à la
place et là je ne vous ai pas montré
mais ne vous en faites pas j'ai
sauvegardé juste avant d'appeler le
transit et n'est-il pas malin le lieu
lui approche retrouver samuel taylor et
les marshall oui sans aucun problème
ripley on est dans le bureau du marshall
tournait à 3 15 escalier vous pouvez pas
le rater
fuck the marshall donc je pense que
c'est là assez bon je pense que c'est
des méchants
je vais tout cas d'autres réfugiés en
fait c'est quoi ce hamels a non
seulement ils ces marchés ok michael
donc apparemment la dépressive va bien
objectifs et à jour par les amarres
l'eau apparemment marleau celui qui a
volé les boîtes noires et veut pas
donner les codes qui permet de ramener
son vaisseau en mode automatique
jusqu'au vaisseau nous dans lequel on
est en gros à cause de ce gros coup que
peut donner des codes on peut pas
s'enfuir
donc mon petit marleau où tu vas venir
et je vais tabassé la tronche à coups de
crosse sétois marleau c'est bien toi
geslin pour des raisons personnelles la
mer était sur le nostromo quand il a
disparu il ya quinze ans on n'a jamais
trouvé son vaisseau au replay juste la
boîte noire mais enfin vous avez vu
aussi trouve autre chose qu'est ce qui
s'est passé là-bas
non non non non on témoin tout voilà en
fait tous les détails
j'aimais riz blé ah bah voilà une petite
cinématique qui fait du bien au regard
des verts ça faisait un peu marre aux
allons doucement je voudrais bien
récupérer la valise en un seul morceau
et on va sortir à objectifs visent à
jour faites un scan du signal en
utilisant l'appareil de pistage
regardez c'est tellement stylet ou la
zone combinaison tranquille avec un
double micro pour un son stéréo 5.1
dolby digital joue on explore la planète
coton je serais tellement pas rassurez
moi à leur place là tu sais pas ce qui
peut se passer
trouver un autre chemin autour de
l'obstruction donc là on joue marchau le
méchant qu'on était en train
d'interroger au bar regardé par là qui
peut me faire la courte échelle non ah
bah voilà
il apparut comme ça comme par magie au
[ __ ] qu'est ce que c'est que ça il ya
des fissures dans la roche reculé je
vais la faire exploser
allez on pose notre bombe
ah merde ça marche et quand même leur
fait plus jamais ça à temps
allez on continue suivez-moi rijst le
courte échelle heures officielles ou
merci ait rien vaisseau objectif mise à
jour trouver la source du signal alors
j'essaie de doubler cette femme qui
apparemment ne veux pas me laisser
passer
non mais les chiottes on pénètre
actuellement dans l'épave dans le côlon
de l'épave en bon sens mais qu'est-ce
que bordel de merde tu as fuck je vais
trouver cette valaisanne est un pas
envie que d'autres glandus trouve cet
endroit alors quelqu'un fait la courte
échelle non aa jr avait été surveillée
il est là pour ça se met y voilà il n'a
pas été payé en tant que tu veilles sur
d'autres planètes et gagner un max
d'argent pour la prime de risque il
était payé en tant que tu vas faire la
courte échelle
cinterion mais que j'ai trouvé signal je
vais aller jeter un oeil what désactiver
la balise de détresse mais ça maintenant
il le touche
madame c'est votre femme vous embête et
que vous voulez à désactiver au fait ça
aussi mettez votre main sur son bras et
vous vous glissez comme ça et ensuite
elle vous traite de psychopathe je sais
pas trop ce qui s'est passé mais la
balise a arrêté d'émettre cet endroit
arrête pas de me surprendre tiens
accroche toi bien amo en bas poussent
vers se faisait au nom et voilà et c'est
ses enfants non mais là les gars faut se
marier d'ici là bas la cinématique il va
s'approcher ça va lui jaillir dans le
dans le casque le regard opa sur deux
soit déjà un [ __ ] ça ne présage rien
de bon bah oui mais bien ta tête de
dents au voilà voilà voilà voilà
exactement comme ça maintenant c'est sûr
ça [ __ ] tête ils vont le ramener dans
le vaisseau pour essayer de le soigner
du kouban c'est comme ça qu'elles
viennent s'y retrouver dans ce [ __ ] de
vaisseau tout je veux tout savoir tout
où est votre vaisseau si on brise je
veux m'assurer communication munication
six et bourrés de connaître leur admis
en pilote auto d'ailleurs [ __ ] il fait
chier c'est par là j'ai quelque chose
pour vous un fusil à pompe à lens
flammes
un [ __ ] de lance flammes j'ai vu dans
le trailer qui avait un put alors cela
me manque pas marshall
c'est un an soit là ou pas c'est un
animal les animaux ont peur du feu yes
je suis prêt marshall
j'ai deux communes pour le piéger allait
prendre une navette de transit et
enjoignent à l'écart de la tour système
je m'occupe des coordonnées terrible et
on est les seuls à pouvoir empêcher
cette 4g c'est parce que pris dans le
chaos
sébastopol est déjà dans le cas où c'est
trop tard pour ça voilà tout ce qu'on
peut faire maintenant c'est ali tué cet
[ __ ]
donc je pense qu'on n'a pas l'ancien
limiter sinon ce serait trop facile on a
500 cartouches voilà je sais pas du tout
ce que ça représente et j'ai même pas
envie de gâcher la moindre cartouche en
faisant ça par exemple direction tour
systech lawrence aller au centre du
serveur moi je vous dis hein la liane il
vient bîmes flammes aux fesses white sa
créature comment on fait pour
l'emprisonner la tour a été construite
pour traiter les composés chimiques
précieux trouvé sur la géante gazeuse
on peut sceller la tour les conduit les
portes ou donc vous construisez une cage
autour des créatures et ensuite ricardo
l'enferment on repasse par là en été
mais yahia 8000 année quoi commandes de
la porte
ouvrir la porte mais gentil ou pas il
est gentil ou pas il est gentil
écoutez j'ai trouvé une arme pour
défoncer stage n une [ __ ] de guitare
le joue un air band bal des ego et hop
là on le séduit alors il faut barrer
absolument tous les chemins possibles à
initialiser le verrou parfait et voilà
où y'a tranquille banon mais c'est bon
temps inquiète tout va bien reçoit la
vienne plutôt là et tulle occupe bien
comme il faut tu fais une interview
voilà revient à justifie faute pas accès
à la maintenance verrouille est
initialisée le verrou ricardo réception
du centre du serveur bouclé bien jouer
va dans la grappe de serveurs discretos
tous puisque tôt discretos ejb comme je
peux alors déjà une petite sauvegarde
familiale les gens notre petit piège est
presque terminée alors on sait tous ce
qui va me tueront pas marché r on n'a
pas vu la ligne de l'épisode presque on
va pas aller trop vite on va pas parler
trop vite aller vraiment aux créatures
de l'ombre démoniaque
aa je t'aime ça va et toi
pour la flotte dilemme aa bien là ouais
voilà va t'en va t'en aller ou pas pas
plus que ça vive de jeu on est plutôt
sera pas des camions
j'aime selon l'ompi tu as tu as dépassé
moins bien voilà vatan verrouiller la
grappe de serveurs au voilà c'est bon
t'es de sortie pour moi ricardo une
petite minute
et merde c'est fermer sa bouche pas où
est la sortie oui l'état du nouveau il
faut plus de temps mais va chier ça y
est c'est vous replay sort de là
maintenant au [ __ ]
oh les gars je me suis laissé aller sur
le clic je suis désolé mais c'est qu'il
m'a fait peur ricardo comment est-ce que
tu as réussi à l'ouvrir
j'ai vu éliminer l'alertent qu'un seule
façon de faire sortir je vais la laisser
s'échapper on l'avait enfermée tu l'as
laissé s'échapper rey plaide ou suis
toujours super prenez l'ascenseur
jusqu'au la banque et mini et ensuite au
point à temps et sous - deux minutes y'a
les interférences c'est bon mais tu es
complètement au conte à un pcb lacoste
une des victimes tirent dessus alors
qu'ils regagnaient leurs maîtres [ __ ]
mais tu fais chier
bon ça pouvait partir en pique-niquant
qu'on commet des pizzas je sais pas et
là on la défonce à coups de je ne sais
pas tout simplement comme ça finalement
non y'a du feu pour tout le monde qui
ont peur voilà what what
ok ok mais ne vous parle même plus un et
je sais pas ce que je dis ça mais je le
dis on se barre d'ici regardez allez
vas-y moulias va chier oh ouais mais non
j'ai même pas s'est elle a donc le
screamer et et a été encore plus
efficace et maintenant aux saillies
allez c'est parti localiser accès
activer le système anti-incendie
c'est super et en plus de ça il ya la
vienne qui est là partout venimeux
regroupés au point dans son eau rester
calme et tu te fous de ma mémé bas mais
ça mais au nom je me réveillais de
nouveau dans le feu et va falloir que je
tue l'android qui est devenu fou ta
gueule problème c'est que j'ai toujours
pas trouvé truc anti-incendie oui mais
non et non je me suis enflammé regard
des badauds planète se charge de lui
ouais [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] je veux
rester en dehors de ça mais non non mais
tu étais pas coûte moite et écoute lui
oh là là est la plus fière j'ai enfin
trouvé ce [ __ ] d'ascenseur ça fait
plaisir ça fait plaisir on peut le dire
mais voilà jean ressaisir en fin de
saison sur la ligne de la science est de
plus en plus dur est derrière dites moi
on a réussi ou aux gens peu plus plus
tard retour très vite dans cette
nouvelle vidéo merci d'avoir regardé
n'hésitez pas à aimer d'épisodes si vous
a plu si cette série vous plaît et puis
je vous souhaite un super jeudi soir où
la détente tranquillement dans un
jacuzzi mme dans une petite bassine
d'eau ce n'est pas des jacuzzis cas de
monde et ça
[Musique]